going now from Don Jr to Eric Trump Eric
Trump pulled one of these tears in my
eyes type stories he went on Fox and
Friends yesterday morning and he says
when news of the indictment broke he was
on a plane and that everyone in the
plane came up to him to hug him and as
always it's like do we believe these
stories guys Justice and and guys I have
to tell you people in this country
understand it I was on a plane I was on
a commercial flight when this whole
indictment broke people were coming up
to me giving me hugs the support is
unbelievable out there because people
understand that we've literally become a
Banana Republic we're now literally a
Banana Republic maybe he means
figuratively they've they've made a
mockery out of our our legal system in
this country yeah so I'm sure that that
happened and you know a lot of them were
really big strong guys some of them were
crying and they said to the flight
attendant bring this man more peanuts
because of how unfairly his family has
been treated and then next thing you
know the pilot came out of the cockpit
saluted Eric Trump and they all did the
Pledge of Allegiance and it was just an
incredible incredible day uh I don't
believe any of it obviously then uh
during the same appearance he tries to
say something about free speech and it
goes very very wrong
yeah
Rachel we're supposed to live in a free
country you're supposed to have freedom
of speech right it's just the number one
thing that makes up our constitution
freedom of phrase freedom of expression
yet you have conservatives all over the
country who are getting de-platformed
their businesses are getting shut down
who is that who is he talking about
Banks stop banking them their their web
service providers decide to turn them
turn them away it is true that web hosts
when they find out that they're hosting
extremist content sometimes we'll say
we're not hosting this nonsense anymore
that is true but they want to pretend as
though the indictment of trump proving
or proving suggesting that even
presidents aren't above the law
is somehow an attack on everybody and as
a follow-up to the Eric Trump thing from
last week remember how last week I
played this clip for you where he
relates
CVS and Tylenol not Tylenol
Tylenol somehow to this indictment
remember this clip every single day and
this is a city I spent a lot of time
with you that is falling apart I went
into literally CVS the other day and you
can't buy Tylenol because it's locked
behind these glass counters because
there's so much theft and there's so
much looting or something yeah so he
wasn't able to get Tylenol at CVS he
then went on Newsmax and told a totally
different version of the story where he
says you actually it's it's Advil you
can't get it Dwayne Reed now people in
other parts of the country may not know
Dwayne Reed Duane Reade is like a more
local
um CVS it's it's similar and they sell
other things as well so wait a second
are you telling me that you first went
to CVS and they had no Tylenol without a
key and then you went to Dwayne Reed and
you couldn't get Advil or was it just
the entire thing was made up in New York
City homeliness is is through the roof I
went into Dwayne Reed the other day did
you and literally you can't buy Advil
and Dwayne Reed without having somebody
come up with a key and unlock you know
those little plastic things that you
pick up yep because there's so much
looting in the city I mean the city is
going to hell right now you look
nationally just about every every
Walgreens CVS Dwayne Reed they're all
locking up all of this stuff as I said
last week my hair product is regularly
locked up now I mean it's in very high
demand ever since I started using it but
um my girlfriend's deodorant is locked
up something I got for my baby daughter
was locked up I don't remember what it
was
might have been like baby Zyrtec was
locked up this has nothing to do with
not Prosecuting or Prosecuting Trump and
whether it's Tylenol or bilinol or
whatever it is I don't believe a word
this guy says but he is not doing well
clearly and I get it to some degree to
see my dad indicted and then begging for
money even though he's supposedly a
billionaire it would probably upset me
as well and that's what I want to talk
about next